el presidente chino ha invitado a
Vladimir Putin a visitar china este
mismo año La idea es desarrollar la
llamada ruta de la seda un proyecto de
conexiones comerciales por tierra que el
presidente chino lleva impulsando más de
10 años Es la segunda jornada en Moscú y
en la agenda hoy priman los asuntos
comerciales sobre todo los hidrocarburos
Rusia ha perdido a su principal mercado
hasta antes de la guerra que era el
mercado europeo y ahora está muy
interesada en colocar todo el gas
posible en el mercado chino también es
muy importante para Rusia encontrar la
manera de llevar a China todos esos
hidrocarburos porque las vías de
comunicación con Oriente no están tan
desarrolladas como estaban las vías de
comunicación con occidente En esta
segunda jornada Vladimir Putin ha vuelto
a recibir en el kremlin ambos han
escuchado los himnos de los respectivos
países y han dado comienzo a una nueva
jornada maratoniana de discusiones que
durará hasta la noche cuando habrá una
cena de estado